we're asked to use the drop-down to form
a linear equation with infinitely many
solutions
so it's an equation with infinitely many
solutions essentially has the same thing
on both sides no matter what X you pick
so first out my brain just wants to
simplify this left hand side a little
bit and then think about how I can
engineer the right hand side so it's
going to be the same as the left no
matter what X I pick so right over here
if I distribute the 4 over X minus 2 I
get 4x minus 8 and then I'm adding X to
that and that's of course going to be
equal to 5x plus blank and I get to pick
what my blank is and so 4x plus X is 5x
5x and of course we still have our minus
8 and that's going to be equal to 5x
plus blank so what could we make that
blank so this is true for any any X we
pick well over here we have 5 times then
X minus 8 well if we if we make this a
minus 8 or if we subtract 80 or if we
make this a negative 8 this is going to
be true for any X so if we make this a
negative 8 this is going to be true for
any X you pick you take give me any X
you multiply it by 5 and subtract 8
that's of course going to be that same X
multiplied by 5 and subtracting 8 and if
you were to try to somehow solve this
equation subtract 5x from both sides you
would get negative 8 is equal to
negative 8 which is absolutely true for
absolutely any X that you pick so let's
go let me actually fill this in on the
exercise so I want to make 5 I wanted
it's going to be 5x plus negative 8